у селищі Покровське що на півдні
Дніпропетровської області тепер все
крутиться навколо
води мама говорит поедьте наберите мне
воды Мама каже поїдьте Наберіть мені
води ми на транспорті на мопеді бо важко
жходити
носити екологічна
катастрофа водопостачання в Покровському
немає а ту воду що привозять у цих
бочках небезпечно пити у місті є трохи
питної води але її не вистачає на всіх
місцеві жителі такі як Ірина борошнова
повинні самі розв'язувати цю проблему та
організовувати собі воду вона запрошує
нас до свого будинку Ірина вчителька
математики і фізики але як І більшість
селян Її родина живе з того що вродить
земля відсутність води навіть для
зрошування стала загрозою для
нормального існування місцевих оце рання
капуста Ну це також пізня видно по листю
чим вона відрізняється це
броколі раніше Вони поливали свій посів
водою з Каховського водосховища але
оскільки дамба була зруйнована цей
варіант поливу для них вже недоступний
вони витратили гроші на Борове
обладнання щоб викопати колодязь 36 м
завглибшки Цю воду вони можуть
використовувати для зрошування полів і
для поливу Території навколо будинку але
пити її не варто коли вранці от там
вмиваюся там чистю зуби да то от вона я
от така якась содово така Прям сольна
таке впечатление що я полоскаю
сольво-содовим роствором оце отак на
смак
вона гуманітарна ситуація залишає
занепокоєння оскільки нестача води все
ще впливає на багатьох жителів цієї
громади не лише поблизу дамби Але й в
інших регіонах які раніше були пов'язані
з цим
водосховищемже права не лише в кількості
а й у якості води місцева громада
страждає і продовжить страждати через цю
нестачу селяни тут у Покровському
відчувають що їх покинули тоді як У
сусідньому Нікополі жителі міста можуть
мати воду та в них є інші турботи звідси
де раніше був берег водосховища видно
окуповану Росією територію Всього за 10
км знаходиться Запорізька АЕС 3 квітня
2022 року вони Зайшли туди з своїми в
військами і в
принципі вже було понятно що вони
будуть нас тероризувати з цього місця
В'ячеслав розповідає нам що місто може
використовувати ту воду яка залишилася у
водосховищі але росіяни намагаються не
дозволяти їм це робити час від часу Їм
вдається влучити в ціль
обстріли залишаються
на сьогоднішній день в в те місце де
знаходиться насосна станція і
получається наразі збільшуються обстріли
для того щоб лишити нас
води місцева Влада працює над постійним
рішенням прокладають труби для з'єднання
Нікополя з водопроводом міста Запоріжжя
зробити це сподіваються дозими після
знищення каховської ГЕС західні команди
швидкого реагування вирушили допо гати
людям на місцях та цього все одно
недостатньо - каже Крістіна фалконі з
норвезької ради
біженців негайна реакція з розподілом
води була потужною норвезька рада
біженців розподіляє понад 200 тон води в
різних місцях і Ми продовжуємо
підтримувати місцеву громаду так само як
і інші організації а також національні
міжнародні та місцеві органи влади
ситуація потребує тривалішого вирішення
місцева Влада працює над цим але як
також згадувалося деякі з цих місць
також є дуже близько до лінії фронту та
щодня знаходяться під обстрілами
Нікополь Марганець Херсон щодня атакують
і звичайно відновлення та будівництво
нових трубопроводів також є надзвичайно
складним
завданням цього сезону Ірина та її
чоловік Володимир з Покровського садили
менше ніж зазвичай знаючи що води буде
мало але вона є посадити більше городини
наступного сезону з Надією що нова
свердловина допоможе зберегти те що є
принаймні на деякий час не так давно
води що наповнювали цей басейн
допомагали годувати Це село Крім того
люди купалися і засмагали на скелях
селяни кажуть що через відсутність води
вовки перепливають з іншого берегу ніхто
не знає чи дамбу відновлять чи природа
заволодіє басейном і тут все заросте
бур'янами може для екосистеми як якоїсь
там для природи для тварин Це буде добре
ну це буде погано для нас для для людей
для жителів саме села узимку ситуація
стане ще складнішою вважають
експерти з приходом зими А це буде друга
зима за час війни ми можемо очікувати що
потреби місцевих збільшаться тому що на
жаль з торішнього досвіду
водноенергетична інфраструктура кілька
разів ставала мішенню в різних регіонах
країни тому ми боїмося що цей додатковий
ризик може ще більше посилити потреби та
вплив на людей у регіонах які
надзвичайно постраждали від браку
води ми працюємо як міжнародне
співтовариство як член міжнародної
спільноти з місцевими партнерами щоб
підготувати відповідь для підтримки цих
зимових потреб і гарантувати якомога
більше більше поставок альтернативних
поставок або зимових рішень для їх
зікрівання знову Протягом наступних
місяців селяни побоюються що якщо
водосховище знову не наповнять їм мабуть
усім доведеться
виїхати